What no way wait
Yes
Sure, I always I always what is to happen, I you dream that this will happen, but I never thought it would really happen
Beautiful
Don't scream slowly turn around
Okay, I know you don't recognize me
I know that and but I'm going to prove to you that I am your friend your good friend, but
Okay, don't scream. No, no
No one is screwed. Don't even make the noise you just made
Okay
Okay. Now I know you don't recognize me you're thinking who is this girl? And why is she here? What was she doing covering hers?
ringing ass mouths
Yukos, it's me
Renee
Full spin
Real at Zuma I go where the ladies go. Oh
You're the go to the gym to pick up chicks guy
No, I'm the guy who sits next to you in high school and wants to ask you out
But I chickened out and then monitor your status hoping that you'll be single after a union but for not it's great
I don't care. You're happy prayer. I'm happy for her
That's not real. By the way, by the way, that's not real. That's me painting a picture. That sounded pretty real
I feel pretty in theaters April 20th. Hi Renee. We can't a minute. It's all psych. Oh my god
Are you okay? Yeah
Kind of as good as can be expected it was too flat there is not not one
I feel pretty in theaters April 20th. You look really beautiful
Yeah
You sure don't look like sort of like a lady of the night like a processor I'm over here boy
No, and they don't talk like that anymore. Well in like Saloon days, I feel pretty in theaters April 20th today
What you always wanted to be?
On April 20th
Rated pg-13. I've been on all these sites. So it even looks at the profile
The picture is all that matters, and I'm sick of it. Thank you for that pep talk. Thank you on April 20th
I've always wanted to be undeniably pretty
You hit your head pretty hard, that's me, yes
Change the way you see yourself I can eat whatever I want and still look like this shout out to my genetic makeup
I feel pretty rated pg-13 today. You're gonna see what you always
You hit your head pretty hard wait, that's me. Yes
What's your number very clever? All right, I'm gonna give you my number are you talking to me? Shake it out now son?
Yes modeling is an option for me. It's not who I am Wow. I feel pretty hated bg-30
I've always wondered what it's like to be undeniably pretty
Are you shopping for a gift kind of browsing for me?
So sizing is a little limited here in the store, but you could probably find your size online. I
Have a crazy idea let's be honest for a minute no matter how many times we hear. It's what's on the inside that matters
Women know deep down. It's what's on the outside that the whole world judges, okay
I'm just like dealing with low self-esteem and like I want to punch you right in your dumb face right now
Do you have every rib that I have?
I've been on all of these sites. No one even looks at the profile. They only care about the picture and I'm sick of it
always wondered what it feels like to be just undeniably pretty
Okay, you hit your head pretty hard
Dixit day, I see you all the day. I know you don't recognize me. That's something you could use. It's me
Renee what's happening? Oh
That's
Really clever. It's forward. What's your number?
Give me your phone when you give you my number. Are you still talking to me? Shake it out now?
Iowa's you this would be quite a large promotion for you. What do you call this? Exactly?
I get it and yes modeling is an option for me
It's not who I am
Things have really changed for me. You just have all the confidence in the world
I think a lot of people completing this the thing that really makes them awesome and you're not like that
DJ hit it
Shimmy shimmy, shimmy, I should be out you might want to
Depose them. I don't know, you know
Sneak peek means you're completely nation
You